your x-men co-star is it James McAvoy he
you guys have kind of a playful
relationship yeah and when you're on set
it's gotten a little out of hand
I understand the work there were times
we this last film we we went out with a
board and when it bought BB guns and
then essentially had full on warfare
shooting bb's at each other they're
shooting we've all God also don't want
to get blinded but then but then yeah
round base camp you wake you wake up in
the morning at like five o'clock in the
morning fumble around for your gun make
sure your clip was loaded and then the
second you got out of the car it was on
essentially you know the people be
waiting in your trailer we had we had
Michael Fassbender stuck in his trailer
for 45 minutes once whilst three of us
were like clambering over it diving
underneath shooting through windows you
mentioned that you guys have goggles but
you didn't tell everyone else to put on
God yeah screw the rest of them say here
you're firing left and right and no one
else has detection yeah that got put to
an end because um people got shot in the
face and then like wealth would pop up
and bleed and then and then it was like
there's a 3d movie so they were you
could see them quite clearly makeup
couldn't cover them after a while so we
had to stop I now know why they were
trying to kill you I picture a mechanic
with welts all over his face
removing the axle from the bike now you
mention it will make it will make sense
it's all coming together now
now I hurt Mac boy hits you in a
sensitive area is that right oh yeah in
the girlies yeah what do you call them
gillies is that it is that a UK thing
Ghoulies I think so
if no I just made it up I never heard of
that I have heard it before I've never
heard of that they're always coming up
with different names for you know
essentially that's all they say balls in
this country but you guys are like oh
it's me kibbles and bits or
it's nice it's me Stan and Laurel you
know and I thought I felt as though
English people do it a little bit when
we're over here anyway where it's just
like we can use whatever where we want
and then the people that like wants that
we can just say it's an English phrase
for something oh and you're making it up
just yes make up we can just use
whatever words we want that's me Conan
and Andy down there that's what Kristen
them yeah no um yeah please don't don't
mind kind of Andy they're always hanging
about the way they're always together
you